Most talked about that.
Like every,
I got calls from all my friend Bert Kreischer was fucking obsessed with you.
He wouldn't stop calling me about it.
He's like,
the fucking guy's by himself through the video with him,
with the grizzly bear,
and he's pointing the gun at it.
Jesus Christ.
Fucking weirdest thing is,
it's,
that's normal shit.
It is.
That's very normal society so removed from it now.
Well,
if you're out there,
it's normal to get false charge by a grizzly bear.
Nycha.
One good reason not fucking be out.
All of the token wave came about this.
Well,
we hopped into the back of Montana to the spot that's usually got a bunch of
grizzly bears that I go to and uh,
we were talking about you,
how you wouldn't come out to Australia.
Hunting could just scan it.
Everything.
The difference is when you walking around the mountains here,
it can happen at any point because fucking grizzly bears to go feet.
They walk on land.
In Australia,
you pretty much have to go into the water.
So you're only worried about that when you go to click water or you're thinking
about having a wash or something here it's full time.
For whatever reason,
it doesn't bother me as much to get killed and eaten by a bear.
Does a giant saltwater CROC.
I reckon the crocodile,
it'd be nicer.
What?
Yeah,
it'd be nicer.
It like grab you and drag you down.
You'd drowned anyway,
you know?
And then it would do what it wants to go at Grizzly bear is gonna fucking
Moliere scratch your face off.
Bite your neck.
Take chunks out of here.
It's going to be longer,
dude.
Yeah,
but it's American.
We're not want no foreign shit.
Fucking no fun is eating to me.
Uh,
there's some about a grizzly bears.
It's most terrifying things that they just eat you.
They don't kill you first.
He just holds you down eating you.
Yeah.
They treat you the same way.
They treat a salmon.
You know,
when you see them hold down salmon and they take big bites out of it,
they don't make sure they killed.
I thought behind it,
you know,
it's like,
yeah,
I'll finish it off first.
And then did you see the mountain lion that I ended up hunting?
He did,
yeah.
And like mountain lions usually kill their prey,
but obviously grabbed the car and it was eaten this calf while it's still alive,
like a beef cow calf video.
Pretty disturbing.
And then I seen one not long ago,
someone shared with me with a mountain lion drag and the mule deer down,
it's like chomping on this mule deer before it actually dies,
you know?
And it's like,
there's just not that thought process there.
There's not that human,
as long as they make sure that they have it as a meal and it's not going
anywhere,
they'll just get it done.
Yeah.
Some friends,
uh,
were elk hunting and they came across as elk who,
these wolves had torn the back legs apart and were a,
it was in the river and the wolves were eating it while it was in the river.
And the thing was moaning and screaming.
It couldn't go anywhere.
But bull elk in the,
in the water.
And they just pretty,
pretty horrible for us,
but I not give a fuck dot standard for them.
Have you encountered any bulls when you're out there?
Yeah,
plenty of times.
Yeah.
The first time I went to Canada was northwest territories and there was a pack
of wolves that that would chase and a Caribou bull and like pretty much chase
this thing to like a lever,
a sweat,
you know,
I like the key.
This is in winter.
So the ball,
the Caribou bull got really hot and like chased it in the freezing cold river
and they sort of surrounded it in the river and then they just left it and they
walked off,
you know?
And it wasn't that they were walking away from their kill,
they knew the job was done,
the wolves went back up high and they got on these rocky benches and sat in the
sun and we're like drawing out their selves and cooling down and drawing out.
And this Caribou never left the river.
It was like just quivering in the river.
And then that afternoon when we come back,
that Caribou was just the caucus.
We've like flesh hanging off the ribs on the side of the river so they come back
down once the river had done his job and item smart as hell.
I that's,
that's really crazy that,
that intelligent that they know it's over.
They're like,
Oh God,
he's in the water in the water.
Like chill now.
Yeah.
That has bananas.
Crazy high.
There are so wise people that I know that I've seen them in the forest say they
look at you a different way.
Did they look at you?
There's a way they look through you.
They look at you in a way like almost like they think that that's the reason why
that the myth of the Werewolf exists as it people that have these terrifying
encounters with wolves.
They swear that it's part human cause you make,
he is into interior.
Yeah.
They're looking into you.
They're figuring you out.
You know,
he's got to think what it would be like if you just out there,
you know,
if you're lucky live five years old,
you'd get this hard scrabble life out there chasing much larger animals than you
and you've got to kill them with your face.
Yeah.
Like a happened or die.
Crazy.
A pack of luck.
30 wolves.
This last trip that I was in BC and I kept coming around camp.
We had horses and not in camp and um,
one die.
I've ventured out to try and get onto them and get a better look at them and
they just,
without seeing me,
they just kept this perfect range,
you know,
like that how back to me,
I was trying to call him Manos Hal and that how back to me and I just keep these
perfect range and you could tell the whole time they'll communicate and cause
then they'd be a novel,
a wolf or a couple of wolves that were like a couple of miles in the other
direction and you could hear them moving the same pattern at the rest of these
walls were.
And I got eyes on him from a distance.
I walked across an ice lake.
And other than that I never really seen him.
But I guarantee you those wolves looked at me a bunch of times.
Like they're just a different hunter dude.
They're trying to figure out what they can do.
Yeah.
So that's,
it's such a eerie feeling too.
So it's like snow and it's like,
why in the back country of British Columbia and like,
I'm going up on these mountains,
it's like big pine trees and everything like that,
and just every direction around your howl and dude,
you'd hear him how and you'd hear him do it sounds like a Bach.
It's not stuck like this.
Short howl.
And then every now and then you'd hear hell different.
And you could tell that that was the alpha.
There's the sound that it was letting out,
dude.
Just like earrings or some place to be if you were in the nature like crazy
place to be,
if you're not into Nycha fucking nightmare,
like,
yeah.